with a famously conservative lead actor
sound of Freedom was already on the path
to controversy add a dash of Q Anon
affiliation and it's no surprise that
the 2023 action flick is Raising
eyebrows across the globe
sound of freedom is one of 2023's most
unexpected success stories within two
weeks of its July 4th release the
independent action thriller grossed over
85 million dollars at the box office and
brought Jim Caviezel back into the
Hollywood spotlight the former The
Passion of the Christ star plays Tim
Ballard a former government agent who
goes Rogue to take down a child
trafficking ring while cavizel himself
has become known for his inflammatory
politics his character draws inspiration
from a real-life figure who's dedicated
his career to a very particular and
controversial line of work
Tim Ballard is a former undercover
operative for the U.S Department of
Homeland Security after leaving the
government agency he founded operation
Underground Railroad a non-profit
organization that's dedicated to
fighting real-life human trafficking
Rings all around the world of course
Ballard's work has also made him a
source of controversy he's outspoken
about his politics and he's been linked
to conspiracy theories pertaining to the
exploitation of children for this reason
sound of Freedom has attracted its fair
share of critics some of whom have big
names Rolling Stones succinctly
summarized their thoughts on the film
writing the Q a non-tinged thriller
about child trafficking is designed to
appeal to the conscience of a conspiracy
adult Boomer
God's children enough for sale
there are aspects to sound of Freedom's
plot that are quite representative of
how Ballard story is reported to have
transpired as the film depicts Ballard
really did quit his job at the
Department of Homeland Security in order
to carry out a rescue mission however
it's the mission in question that starts
to separate the film from reality
in sound of Freedom Ballard quits his
job to rescue a young girl from the
hands of a Colombian child trafficking
organization however while speaking to
the Daily signal Ballard explained that
his Federal superiors told him to abort
missions in both Haiti and Colombia
which he refused to do as he felt it
defeated the purpose of his duties
Ballard described both those missions as
major cases which could have had huge
impacts on human trafficking worldwide
when he received instructions to come
home he refused in the same interview
Ballard revealed that he was able to
carry out the missions thanks to funding
from Glenn Beck a conservative political
commentator who's worked for CNN Fox
News and the Blaze TV
after completing the rescues Ballard
formed operation Underground Railroad in
2013. according to the foundation's
website the group works with government
and law enforcement agencies both
domestically and internationally to
device strategies that will assist in
the fight against human trafficking
these strategies include Gathering
intelligence offering resources and
providing care to survivors they've also
been known to carry out sting operations
and share the footage of their rescues
on social media while the operation
underground railroads efforts seem Noble
in theory they have also been the
subject of some controversy most notably
the organization has been linked with Q
Anon a far-right conspiracy theory
movement that believes Democratic
politicians and Hollywood celebrities
are involved in the operation of child
trafficking ranks Ballard and operation
Underground Railroad have denied any
association with the movement but their
methods for researching and spreading
the word about human trafficking are
markedly similar discussing Q Anon with
New York Times Ballard even stated some
of these theories have allowed people to
open their eyes so now it's our job to
flood the space with real information so
the facts can be shared
these days however even Ballard appears
to be distancing himself from operation
Underground Railroad Vice reported that
he parted ways with the organization
before sound of Freedom was released and
he has since co-founded a new Endeavor
known as the spear fund
[Music]